you're looking at austin
voth on the year 015 with an 8.26 era
talking to dave martinez his manager
before the game said his velocity has
been down this year
both against ocuna junior
this one's popped up acuna is begging
for it to get out of play but it won't
and he's retired i i love
i love the attitude when you get a pitch
you should have hit and you missed it
but he took the fastball
a 5 foot 11 left-hander gets the ball
for the atlanta braves
in a depleted starting rotation for
brian snicker yeah and this the best
pitch that
robbie featured would be the curveball
you're going to see it early you're
going to see it often
down the line trey turner comes through
and our first run of the ball game
will go to the washington nationals i
was going to say look at him get a
triple out of this
you know why he got a triple on this
ball because it's a ball hit
that if they catch it it's a double play
potential you're the base runner
and you're running i don't need that
third base coach if the ball's behind me
i might need him
but in front my view is here all i got
to do is look
make sure i touch the bag and i'm
reading this all the way
so you saw trey never have to stop
because you don't need a coach
that's in front of you irwin faces juan
soto
and dan once again they shoot it down
the line
they're up there swinging at the first
pitch well one of the difficulties that
he's had this year and you touched on
the numbers a big distinction between
the righties and lefties
he has a difficult time greg getting the
ball down and away
the ball hangs around in that inner
third upper part of the plate where
lefties they bail a little bit
and you're throwing the ball right to
where he leaks lefty's hitting over 400
this year against robbie orleans now two
nothing as as drupal cabrera digs in as
we see as druva drill one into the
oh it got by and we're gonna keep
running the bases
my goodness what a half inning but the
point is greg when the ball's in front
of you
you don't need a coach right there again
the ball's in front of the runner in
left field
so cabrera doesn't need the coach that's
why you can
make that decision i see a lot of kids
and even in college
where they're looking at a coach it's in
front of you let your instincts take
over
with two outs and a runner on third base
you have to go after me does
eaton sends this one deep to right and
adam eaton's second
level greg as a leadoff guy
that makes me want to cry watching that
a b
because he used everything in his
toolbox if you're gonna play me back
i'm gonna get a bunt and what'd it do
force him to throw a breaking ball and
bounce it now we're gonna throw me two
and l
now i got to where i want you and he got
a fastball and i mean he hammered it
upper tank he knew what we were talking
about the man they call spanky
tons of persons get that car going no
he's not there
that is on the il acuna at first loves
to run here's freddie freeman
about as good of a two-hole hitter as
you're gonna see in the sport
and i think dj dan needs to
clear the vocals get him ready and give
us what we need dan freddy freebird
his head on a pillow made of concrete
yes he does
that's the first hit of the night for
the braves and it makes the score 5-2
so braves not done we got a ball game
now
both out of the game in is wander suera
first pitch
is clobbered over the right field wall
by who
roland cunha jr doing what we were
expecting to do
to begin the nights i just had the wrong
pitcher it's okay harold
gomes trying to get the run home you can
watch soto go down the line
he's going to go down the line harrison
is going to get off now this is
where the third baseman's at for tells
you that they're not throwing through
because they're not going to make that
play he's that's why he's running on
this it's going to be a sacrifice
that 0-2 pitch caught a ton of play a
ton of play
rbi for john gomes good piece of hitting
and an insurance run for the washington
nationals 6-4 the score
we saw them run three pitches in a row
and that's how much they wanted to get
that run a lot of teams don't do that
we've got a game folks runners on the
corners
in the sixth the braves down by two go
ahead run coming to the plate
one long pitch up the middle they're
gonna double them up a gift
for finnegan wow that's an important
play
well that's a back breaker yeah first
and third no ounce
the ball wasn't scorched no it wasn't
scorched but scores them
so he reaches and thank goodness will
harris got the double play
earlier in this ending freeman may have
struck again
go ahead dan
this game is tied folks freddie
freeman's second home run
of the night last seven games five home
runs and 20 rbis
look at this look at his head he stays
so balanced
as dansby swanson is at the play oh
98. swanson
just gave the braves the lead to what
the braves do
29 runs last night but man
i mean right center field like
in a blink of an eye that ball is out so
pretty slow
oh this doesn't look thankful there goes
head athletic trainer paul
assard as soon as he lets this ball go
and he lands
you'll see a little bit of a recoil so
the gnats have the time running first
hernandez in the game brock holt long
time red sox
this fly ball to center will be handled
by inciarte and the braves come back
wow down at one point five nothing
they tied it and swanson solo's shot
was the difference